d'accord vraiment monter les cols
étaient ravis de vous avoir comme
deuxième invité merci malheureusement
c'est pas fini pour vous
tavaux mais non elle a l'air d'une
compétition et vous savez qu'une bonne
compétition vaut mieux qu'une mauvaise
excuse
oui vous êtes prêt toujours on y va
jacques c'est la première fois que vous
entrez dans un confessionnal
oui quel effet ça vous fait je vous
dirais que j'aime beaucoup l'atmosphère
des églises la tenancière du sacré et
donc ça me fait le même effet vous êtes
déjà allongé sur le divan d'un psy qu'un
d'un petit quart d'heure même pour
rigoler pour rigoler mais avec des gens
qui n'étaient pas si ma mère n'avait pas
besoin de porter l'étoile jaune
elle était jaune de la tête aux pieds
c'est cette sensibilité de colonisés qui
a guidé votre vie je crois oui c'est
pour ça que vous avez défendu barbie non
pas comme un tortionnaire nazi mais
comme membres d'une armée d'occupation
comme l'armée française en algérie où
l'armée américaine au vietnam où l'armée
russe en afghanistan pour moi barbie est
un personnage tragique de notre temps
seul officier subalterne d'une armée
d'occupation
dans un pays qui résiste vous avez dit
comme roger nimier tout humanisme et
étrangers expliqué bon je veux dire ceci
c'est que il y à une certaine morale qui
se cache derrière les mots humaniste
derrière les mots droits de l'homme qui
exprime le
l'état de la société en europe à l'heure
actuelle cette morale cette vision du
monde qui n'aimait pas général
d'ailleurs est le résultat du lycée est
l'aboutissement d'une histoire et je
trouve que vouloir imposer cette vision
du monde à tous les pays à toutes les
nations c'est faire fi de leurs cultures
différentes de leur histoire différente
leur vision du monde qui est différente
c'est manifestement n'avoir pas du
spengler est ce que vous auriez dévolu
adolf hitler
s'il était venu me voir et qu'il m'avait
dit je suis certainement l'homme dans
l'histoire du monde
this est l'objet des accusations et plus
grand je crois que c'est incontestable
mon procès effet d'avancer encore une
cause perdue mais parmi les millions
d'avocats qui en allemand je pense que
vous êtes le seul capable de donner à
mes actes leurs frais signification leur
vraie dimension show nantes pâte
m'excuser je vous demande de décrire
enfin de donner à ma vie sa dîme sa
véritable dimension à ce moment là je
crois que j'aurai accès pendant les six
ans vous avez disparu vous étiez où
quelque part vous le dirais jamais vous
savez les liaisons qu'elle soit
amoureuse aux politiques qu'on cache son
peu j'aurais plus ça vous fait mal
d'être en effet pas raté d'abord
écrivain raté il aurait fallu que je
sois le jeune volonté d'être écrivain
jeu ici à lille s'est fait l'agent d'un
qu'il se ressaisir ça dépend et comme on
le prend mais le ce que je voulais dire
c'est le travail d'avocat dans comme je
conçois est un travail de création aussi
avec son originalité c'est quoi la
beauté du crime
la beauté du crime c'est cela ne veut
pas dire que tous les crimes sont beaux
la beauté du greaves et que certains
crimes prennent une signification
universelle
est-ce que vous avez le sens du péché
non